[Music]  look out there out there is the perfect  laughs you see it I think so most people  can't tell Shelby  maybe the Iacocca Ford Motor suppose  henry ford ii wanted to build the  greatest race car the world's ever seen  to win the 24 Hours of LeMans what's it  take I'll take something money can't buy  what he can buy speed put in about speed  you need a pure racer behind a wheeler  car I scan miles I don't trust him an  inch we heard he's difficult no no Ken's  a puppy dog  [Music]  No whatever it is she'll now trust me  you're gonna build a car to beat Ferrari  with a correct  and how long did you tell us that you  needed to 300 years 90 days  this isn't the first time where'd motors  gone to war we know how to do more than  push paper go ahead girl go to war thank  you sir  do you think you can beat Ferrari  lighter faster  that don't work for nastier  we're gonna make history  you ready I was born ready mr. Shelby  hit  [Laughter]  [Applause]  [Music]